[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بكم مرة أخرى في لعبة الجولف الحية حيث
نتواجد هذا الشهر في بطولة إيفيون الرابعة للسيدات لهذا العام
قبل
بدء حدث هذا الأسبوع، أجلس
مع واحدة من أكثر اللاعبين المحتملين إثارة
في تاريخ اللعبة، اللاعب الذي
فازت في وقت سابق من هذا العام بأول
حدث لها في جولة LPGA كمحترفة بعد أن
أصبحت بالفعل الهواة الأكثر تتويجًا على
الإطلاق،
روز تشانغ،
لذلك دعونا نبدأ بالحديث عن
حياتك المبكرة وكيف دخلت
لعبة الجولف، لذلك كنت
طفلًا نشيطًا للغاية  أثناء نشأتي، لعبت الكثير
من الألعاب الرياضية المختلفة وكان لوالدي
تأثير كبير حقًا فيما يتعلق
بالخروج واللعب عندما كنت
طفلاً صغيرًا
ولكن صديق والدي أجبر
والدي في الواقع على ممارسة لعبة الجولف من هناك، لقد
انضممت إليه نوعًا ما وأردت ذلك  تعرف على
معنى لعبة الجولف هذه وبدأت أتأرجح في
الفناء الخلفي لمنزلي ووقعت في حبها
منذ ذلك الحين، لذا فأنت أكثر
لاعبة ضرر للسيدات تزينًا على الإطلاق، كيف
تعتقد أن تجربتك في لعب
الجولف الجامعي في ستامفورد ساعدت في
تشكيلك كشخصية  لاعب أعتقد أنه ساهم في
تشكيل شخصيتي تمامًا فقط لأنني كنت
ألعب جيدًا كلاعب مبتدئ
وعندما كنت بحاجة إلى اتخاذ قرار
بشأن ما إذا كنت أرغب في الالتحاق
بالجامعة ومتابعة شهادتي أم لا، لمجرد كوني
لاعب غولف جامعي والتواجد بين الناس
عمري مستوحى من مدى
روعتهم في حد ذاتها، وهذا
حقًا ما دفعني لأن أصبح أفضل
بمفردي، دعنا نتحدث عن
فوزك كهاوٍ في بطولة أوغوستا الوطنية للسيدات،
كيف كان الأمر كذلك وكذلك في
بطولة الماسترز التي أتى فيها تايجر وودز
انتهى وأتحدث إليك ماذا قال
أن الأسبوع بأكمله كان أسبوع أحلام فقط
لأنك تعلم عندما تحدثت إلى تايجر
كان بصراحة أي شيء يخرج
من فم تايجر وعندما يوجهه
إليك فهو بالفعل تعلم أنني
بالفعل  في رهبة، نعم، أنا أستمع وقد
قال للتو تهانينا لقد
رأيتك على شاشة التلفزيون ولا يمكنني أن أكون أكثر
فخرًا ببطاقة Go الخاصة بك، لذلك كان من
الرائع حقًا أن تحصل على القليل من
لحظة الارتباط التي أعطتك
إنه بالتأكيد بمثابة دفعة صغيرة، لا
أعلم أنه أمر لا يصدق كيف
ذهب إلى جامعة ستانفورد أيضًا
وأعتقد أن هذا هو الرابط الصغير بيننا
ولكن في نفس الوقت تعلم أن تايجر
وودز هو تايجر وودز، لقد
غير اللعبة تمامًا وقام بتحديثها
وكنت سعيدًا حقًا بوجودي في
حضوره ومشاهدته وهو يلعب تدريباته
بينما كان يضرب قميصه في اليوم
الثاني عشر، تحدثت عن الضغط
والتوقعات بوضوح مع مثل هذه
النجاحات المبكرة، كيف تتعامل مع
هذا النوع من المشاكل داخليًا  سأقول مثل
شخصيتي الأساسية، فأنا مسيحي متدين في الأساس،
لذا يعرف الكثير منكم أن الذهاب إلى
الكنيسة والذهاب إلى مجموعات الكنيسة
مع أشخاص
يمجدون الله حقًا، هو دائمًا
شيء أرغب في القيام به في
مهنتي الخاصة.  حياتي الخاصة ولهذا السبب أنا ما
أنا عليه